people are going to sporting events that
are bigger than this this is a
sophisticated vaccinated crowd
sophisticated is code for very wealthy
and democrats the peasants have a very
different standard
than the lords and ladies and royalty of
the unspecified gender who attend barack
obama's birthday party
happy birthday to obama he's the only
person who gets to have
a really big birthday party now listen
here's my feeling about birthday parties
or parties of any sort at this point
it's a free country do what you want i
myself
would be happy to have a birthday party
for my wife for any of my relatives
masculists as you know i don't care my
feeling at this point
is that every adult in the united states
every person in the united states above
the age of 12
has had the ability to get the vaccine
once you've had the vaccine your chances
of dying
from cova 19 drop down to very close to
zero
if you get a breakthrough of the delta
variant and you're vaccinated the high
likelihood is that you're going to end
up with a mild cold
and thus if there's a party and somebody
shows up is unvaccinated
and that person gets infected by a
vaccinated person that one is on them so
on a pure principled level i don't care
whether barack obama has a masculist
party but
but the entire democratic infrastructure
has decided
that for the sake of being a good
american
you must mask up you must you know if
you're a vaccinated person
you must put on that mask to protect
everybody else if you're a good
patriotic american you would not hold a
large party for your own 60th
birthday and you certainly wouldn't fly
in your friends
like john kerry to come in maskless on a
private jet in the middle of global
warming which by the way did happen john
kerry did take a private jet
to barack obama's party and uh and then
everybody at the party
took off the masks and one of the djs
there
made the unfortunate error of actually
tweeting out the photos
and then had to delete all the photos
some of the footage was out there
already however
and and things were unfortunately leaked
to the public i say unfortunately even
though it's actually quite fortunate
because i think it's quite important
that the american people know
that the elites who tell you that you
need to mask up the elites who tell you
that life can never go back to normal
these same elites do not hold themselves
to the same standard
at all at all and this has always been
the case with the left
when it comes to the left the people at
the top of the echelon are not
interested in abiding by the rules they
promulgate for everybody else
the people at the top of the elite
though those the elitists in our society
the people
in hollywood and they will abide by the
basic
rules of success in the united states
while ensuring ensuring that everybody
else doesn't
and this is basically charles murray's
book coming apart he talks about the
fact that you have
very liberal elites living off of sunset
boulevard who promulgate social
standards they themselves do not hold by
and so they become rich and they do
really well and many of them are married
and many of them stay married
and then they promulgate values that
everybody else holds by and those people
take those standards seriously and they
wreck their lives well the same thing
holds true
when it comes to things for example like
whether to have a maskless birthday
party
you the peasant are not supposed to have
a maskless birthday party
in fact one of our writers over at daily
wire rides vedra
he tweeted out recently that his
grandfather just died alone in the
hospital of covid
because there have been all of these
revised protocols that suggested you
couldn't go in and visit a dying loved
one who had coveted whether you were
vaccinated or whether you were not
vaccinated because
after all you might spread it to
somebody and so they died so people are
dying alone in the hospitals again
meanwhile barack obama is having a party
so this is where
i start to get up tight not when
somebody has a party i don't care i live
in florida a lot of people haven't
parties
what i care about is if you promulgate a
standard where no one else is supposed
to have a party
just like nobody else is supposed to
take a private jet except for john kerry
just like nobody else
is supposed to hold by sort of
traditional moral standards apparently
except for
many of the people in hollywood who
actually counter-intuitively do
it's the same thing here everybody else
is supposed to mask up and watch grandma
die alone but barack obama gets to have
himself the big party with john legend
singing at the party and everybody
partying without the masks here's a
little bit of the footage
you can see in the background barack
obama partying on stage
there he is going at it really enjoying
himself hugging people on stage
again this isn't an indoor scenario i
was reliably informed by the cdc by
rachelle wolinski by our most
trusted physicians by dr anthony fauci
you shouldn't be having events like this
i was told and i was told by all the
democratic higher-ups in fact
barack obama fibbed and he said he was
going to cancel
the party or at least wildly downgrade
the size and scope of the party and then
of course
he just quietly re-upped the party and
then all this information
started emerging again so you might
think that at this point the media would
be
somewhat critical of this i mean after
all barack obama is a pretty important
person he's the former president of the
united states and we've been informed
that former presidents of the united
states are not just important they are
the most important people when donald
trump
puts out a statement on his email list
it immediately
rockets around the internet because it's
so damned important
when barack obama has a masculist
birthday party you might assume that the
media would be like well that's that's
odd right i mean that's worthy of
coverage well you would be wrong
instead you'd have the cnn white house
correspondent saying it's different guys
it's different because these are the
sophisticated people
you are a rube you're a person who has a
nine to five job who still has to go to
work you're not somebody
who became president of the united
states and then made just a butt load of
money
after having been president of the
united states by being a prominent
politician
you go you like have a regular job and
you need to go to work
but that's the problem you you're the
problem
you peasant you but barack obama is not
a peasant and the people at his parties
they are not the peasants right the the
peasants have a very different standard
than than the lords and ladies and
non-specified and and
and royalty of unspecified gender who
attend barack obama's birthday party
here's the cnn white house correspondent
noting that this is it's a different
thing when barack obama does it then
when you do it
get a party in your own home for your
kid's birthday
that was bad but barack obama he's
turning 60 and let me just tell you that
dude deserves a big birthday party
other people said you know this is
really being overblown
they're following all the safety
precautions people are going to sporting
events that are bigger than this
this is going to be safe this is a
sophisticated vaccinated crowd
and and this is just about optics it's
not about safety by sophisticated and
vaccinated
what they mean sophisticated is code for
very wealthy and democrats
that's what sophisticated means in white
house correspondent for cnn language
that's what that means okay now this has
a pretty predictable effect when all the
elites in a particular society decide
that everybody is supposed to live one
way and they are supposed to live
another
this creates wild institutional distrust
but it also
creates a standard where politicians are
incentivized to pursue some of the
dumbest policies ever so when the media
and the democratic establishment
say over and over and over again that
masking is going to be the solution to
the pandemic when asking pretty
obviously is not vaccination
is the obvious solution to the pandemic
and at this point the solution to the
pandemic
is let everybody live their own life and
then bear the consequences of their own
decision-making
which means that the government really
has very little public policy role at
this point at all but
it has bled down to the american people
and this is why this is a story because
barack obama and the rest of the
democratic party and joe biden and dr
anthony fauci
and all the various members of the
democratic establishment the lori
lightfoots of the world who
said you couldn't get a haircut but she
needed her hair done that was a very
important thing or nancy pelosi
who said that you couldn't get a haircut
mask list but she definitely could
or mayor muriel bowser who is who she
should listen she had to have a picture
masculist with dave chappelle
like while everybody else was masking up
it was super duper important
you the regular people are supposed to
change your life not just for now
forever and they've changed what the
standard is supposed to be
forever they've set up this incentive
structure and this is what pisses me off
you convinced a huge number of americans
to believe in things that
are not reality and not related to
reality you're scaring the hell out of
people
based on bad data it's one thing to
scare the hell out of the unvaccinated
and say to them that you have a much
higher chance of dying from cover 19
than the vaccinated
that's true i mean now let's be real
about this the the rate of death
among young unvaccinated americans
remains
very low i mean compared to any other
disease like smallpox
or any global pandemic that people have
considered a mass killer in the past
the grand total number of americans
under the age of 30 or between the ages
of 20 and 30 who have died in the united
states
is still just a couple of thousand
people i think it's like 2 500 2600
people according to the cdc
as of last week but you do have a much
better chance of dying
if you're unvaccinated then if you're
vaccinated for sure for sure
okay but they're not just restricting
their crazy standards to the
unvaccinated they're extending it to the
vaccinated they're basically saying
you're supposed to be scared
in perpetuity who's got two thumbs and
wants you to like
and subscribe